what should I play in the opening or
what type of opening what opening should
I play and the question is obviously
relates to both white as well as black
and there's no definitive answer really
really is a matter of taste and style
but if you're familiar with any of my
lectures you've heard me talk about the
battlefield right the chessboard and
what are the long diagonals and it's
really interesting regardless of what
opening you play in defense you play
it's like these oh these long diagonals
are like magnets for the bishop just you
know you play a game and then suddenly
you realize your bishops on the open
that on the long diagonal and so with
that in mind and the idea that bishops
do belong on the lung diagonals because
they're the most effective diagonals why
doesn't everybody just fianchetto their
bishops from the get-go just being
shadow your bishops and you'll be happy
so when I was a kid one of my favorite
defenses was what we called the kingside
fianchetto what we called in Seattle by
the way the rat and we would just
fianchetto our King's Bishop and my idea
is black and I'll be speaking to this
defense as from the perspective of the
black player so I'll just actually flip
the board for a second control control
flip there we go
so normally speaking the white pieces
are always at the bottom and the black
pieces are always at the top I'll just
with it because I'm talking about the
opening or in this case the defense from
blacks point of view so what my idea is
I'd put my Bishop here where it would be
on
the long diagonal then I put my knight
on f6 and I Castle and I have built a
fortress right that was what I was
trying to do and what is it that we're
trying to do in the opening as black
what are we trying to do with the
defense against for example efore well
what we're trying to do is fight for the
center that's what we want to do we want
to fight for our fair share of the
center and to be very specific when I
talk about the center I'm talking about
these 16 squares right here in the
center of the board we're trying to
control the center that's our first
basic strategy of the defense we're
trying to develop our pieces or get good
squares for our pieces so we want
central control and development and
thirdly and most importantly we want a
safe King we're very very modest in our
goals and what we're trying to do so
what I strongly recommend is to have you
in your repertoire what we would call
the accelerated dragon I just even like
the name of the defense the accelerated
dragon you know is not just good enough
that you should play the dragon
variation of the Sicilian but you should
play the accelerated dragon of the
Sicilian so what's the idea of the
accelerated dragon of the Sicilian well
first of all my approach to when my
opponent plays efore my approach as from
the perspective of the defender is
twofold the first type of defense is
where I attack the pawn on e4 and I can
do that by playing d5 which is called
the Scandinavian I can play the
Alekhine's I can play the caro-kann any
or I can play a French defense any
defense with the idea of immediately
attacking the e4 pawn is one type of
defense a second type of defense is to
say to white
okay congratulations you got your pawn
on e4 I'm going to leave you alone you
leave me alone I'll leave you alone and
the Sicilian is the secondary type of
Defense
we're basically black is saying - white
congratulations you keep your spawn in
the center of the board which is a good
thing for white this pawn on e4 after
all does control squares f5 and d5 and
you leave me alone and I'm going to play
C 5 and this pawn controls two of your
squares so tit for tat
you've got your thing going I've got my
thing going so this is the Sicilian
defense c5 now white hasn't what a wide
range of possibilities but as we're
going to see what I'm really trying to
do is fianchetto my King's Bishop and
create a fortress on the Kings side so
I'll have a safe king so what I want is
my fair share of the center I want good
development for my pieces and I want a
safe King so that's all I'm trying to do
as black when I play the accelerated
Sicilian okay so white plays Knight f3
by far this is the most popular move by
far other that while there is a large
number of moves that white can choose
from y can choose for example to go into
what is called the closed Sicilian or he
can play the c3 Sicilian and play for D
for D to d4 and get a big center by far
the most popular move is Knight f3 and I
will go back in a moment to look at
alternative moves on move to for white
and why they shouldn't bother you okay
that you can accept them but by far this
is considered the most aggressive
move by today's modern theoreticians
night f3
I play the move Knight c6 okay you
develop your knight I develop my Knight
and again White has about not such a
wide variety of choices he can again go
for the move c3 he can even play for g3
but again the most popular move by far
for white is d4 and this initiates what
is called the open Sicilian once these
pawns get traded the position becomes a
little bit more open there's a pair of
pawns they go off the board so that's
why it's called the open Sicilian we
take the pawn Knight takes d4 and again
the variation we want to concentrate on
this evening is a fee in shadowing our
King's Bishop and we do it exactly in
this move order we first play our Knight
to c6 and then we play g7 g6 now again
from our point of view we don't really
care too much what our opponent does but
from what what we're trying to do is
very simple we're trying to fianchetto
our Bishop to g7 which we are going to
do bring our knight to f6 Castle and
actually we're going to be very pleased
with ourselves why because we notice
that we have two pawns in the center of
the board and our opponent only has one
we've traded essentially this pawn on c7
for what was this pawn on d2 so at the
end of the day we're actually going to
have more central control than our
opponent thanks to the fact that we have
an extra pawn in the center it's that
simple
now White has two main lines here
there's not really that much else to
choose from he can play the move c2 c4
which sets out what is called the Morosi
buying
position oh I don't even like the sound
of that and being bound or he could play
what we call the accelerated dragon with
Knight c3 we're going to concentrate on
this move for a moment and by the way do
feel free to ask questions raise your
hand let me know if you have question
but this move Knight c3 is very popular
okay so in 93 developing a piece and
Bishop g7 in turn developing our piece
notice that with this move Bishop g7 by
the way we set up a very concrete thread
if you don't answer this threat I'm just
going to play Knight takes Knight next
I'm a piece of boy I was the most
successful opening of all time okay one
of the things that we really really want
light to do is we really want white to
capture our Knight because if we were to
capture our Knight this really helps us
tremendously in our battle for the
center
notice that our we recaptured using the
strategical capture towards the center
our pawn now on c6 our newly minted pawn
on c6 controls the squared D 5 which is
very good at hampering this knight's
movement and also notice that the B file
has been opened to blacks advantage so
blacks natural play in the future will
involve moves like rook b8 and perhaps
even Queen a5 putting pressure on this
knight on c3 again thanks to our
fianchettoed Bishop so it would be a
strategic mistake for white to trade
nice ok
the most natural move for white is
Bishop III obviously where is it you
mean Barry yeah there we go okay
defending his knight and of course
developing his piece our opponents
pretty clever he understands what he's
doing
besides capturing our knight on c6 our
opponent might even consider retreat
retreating his Knight to b3 or
retreating is 92 personally it's never
bothered me wherever our opponent wants
to retreat let him retreat like hey good
we got him to retreat okay first of all
any retreat would mean that the knight
would be moving again and white would be
falling behind in development so Bishop
e3 is absolutely White's
best move okay and here black has kind
of come to a crossroads in a normal
dragon Sicilian the idea for black is to
play the move d7 d6 and when we play the
move d7 d6 this is what gives this
variation its name the dragon so if we
take all the pieces off the board and we
just look at this structure for just a
second we imagine that this is a dragon
this is kind of like the head of the
dragon the body of the Dragon the wing
of the Dragon and that's where the name
the dragon Sicilian gets its name from
so with the move d7 d6 we properly
transpose into a dragon Sicilian what
our move order is intended to achieve is
that we don't want to push our pawn to
d6 too early we want to leave that
option for ourselves of maybe maybe
e playing the move d7 d5 and one go if
we can do that not only will we
accelerate beyond being simply equal we
could have an advantage but of course is
we realize right now the idea of playing
d7 d5 in this position makes no sense
pawn on e4 and the knight on c3 both
cover protect attack the square d5 okay
so after Bishop e3 we play the move
Knight f6 this is our main there's a
second why does it keep asking me laughs
do it okay
main line okay so what we're trying to
do now is of course we've prepared our
fortress we're going to hide our king
we're going to be perfectly safe over
here on the King side we hope we'll find
out in the moment but we'll we'll have
fortified our King position and notice
that now with the knight on f6 I want to
play d7 d5 in one go because my knight
and my queen will protect the will
support the advance of our pawn to d5
now there's a lot of reasons subtle
reasons for this tricky move order by
black you're trying to avoid something
that I won't go into great detail about
is you're trying to avoid the dangers of
a normal dragon Sicilian and you're
trying to push your opponent into a
narrow path you're unlike the modern
defense or the rat that I was trying
that I was playing as a kid what you're
trying to do is narrow White's choices
dramatically okay so
let's kind of sum up what's happened for
the moment we've got decent development
right for the moment you know we've got
our fair share of the center and we're
about to have a safe King so if I could
ask the class their opinion what what do
you think white should do in this
specific position okay just throw out
some suggestions for what would be good
moves for white
sir Queen d2 okay so with the move Queen
d2 which is a very normal looking move I
mean you develop a piece nothing wrong
with that it seems from our point of
view that also with a move Queen d2
you've connected your king and rook
giving you the option of perhaps
castling queenside and whatever and a
moment ago when I was talking about the
the variation the Kasparov favored
against the rat maybe just maybe you
have it in mind that you want to disturb
my king side with the move Bishop h6
however the move Queen d2 actually has a
drawback after the move Queen d2 notice
that a moment ago when your Queen was on
d1 it protected the square g4 and didn't
make this jump Knight g4 I didn't have
this option now that you put your queen
on d2 I have the option of playing
Knight g4 with a very very clear
intention of eliminating your Bishop if
I can eliminate this Bishop for this
Knight it means I forever take away your
possibility of playing Bishop h6 and
trading off what I think
is a very powerful bit Bishop that is on
the long diagonal and it turns out this
very natural move Queen d2 gets white
actually into a spot of trouble after
the move Knight g4 so another suggestion
for white
what else could white do that would make
you feel unhappy you want me to guess
okay well I have mentioned that in the
background there is a battle that is
going on for control of the d5 square
black wants to play d5 so in this
position by far the most popular move
according to the ripka book is the move
Bishop c4 okay so the idea behind Bishop
c4 is not only is white developing a
piece good for him but he's also
controlling the square d5 which was your
secret ambition because you have not
advanced your pawn earlier like in a
normal dragon your secret ambition had
been to play the move d5 so this wise
guy on the other side of the board has
already preempted your plan before you
can even put it into effect pretty
clever huh let's look at another move
that white could make now when I started
Elektra I explained that this capture on
c6 is something that black welcomes if
you trade that knight on c6 this this
trade works out into blacks favor
however after this trade in this
specific position there is a white does
have a motivating reason for making that
trade in this exact position because now
he can advance this pawn and the Rat
Fink the dirty rat fink he desert
he disrupts our natural development we
were so happy a moment ago we're about
to put our king over here behind our
fortress walls and claim that we were
nice and safe and look at this our
opponent has already provoked this and
attacked our night ok our night has two
squares that it could move well
more squares but the best squares to be
considered are 95 as well as the retreat
night g8 a lot of grandmasters have
played the move Knight d5 Knight takes
d5 pawn takes Queen takes d5
purposefully sacrificing a pond for
black their idea was that with the move
rook b8 we're getting counter play
against the pawn on b2 as well as ideas
like Queen c7 attacking the pawn on e5
as well as ideas of just simply castling
and playing d6 blasting open this long
diagonal a lot of games have been played
in Grandmaster practice and the overall
view is that unfortunately this gambit
is not good for black and I agree with
that but white has done nothing wrong
and so we can't punish white for his
place thus far and I like the move
Knight g8 that's my recommended move ok
so even though it's a temporary setback
right we've been forced to retreat don't
be too upset don't be too upset we are
threatening to capture the pawn on e5
and if we do we win a pump we're happy
so white usually protects his pawn
clever boy
F for protecting his pawn on e5 and now
we see that our Knight has a problem
we've got to get the knight into the
game so it's very natural for us to play
this move Knight h6 but here's the great
benefit of the knight being on h6 is
it's about to come to the f5 square
where we attack the bishop and it will
be nicely in the center so let's just
continue this line for a moment and the
line as I remember it goes like Queen f3
castles and I believe white castles here
if I'm not mistaken and now we play the
move f7 f6 so what the idea of white a
blacks play is to blast open this long
diagonal to open up his Bishop and put
his knight on f5 well again the
Grandmaster practice has actually
confirmed that blacks position is pretty
darn good that this is a good position
and the results are actually that black
scores better than white does in other
words grandmasters play has proven that
blacks position is not only resilient
it's actually good he scores well so
we're going to go back to our mainline
position and we're going to go to the
move Bishop c4 as our main move I think
that's the one at the top yeah okay
before I continue are there any other
moves that you would consider for white
we've looked at Queen d2 we've looked at
Knight takes c6 and we're about to look
at the main main variation Bishop c4 any
other mooks all of these moves look
pretty purposeful for both sides okay
let's see is that online no we're not
going to worry about that yet
we'll look at the move F 2 F 3 a.m. in a
moment we can come back to that move in
a moment instead we're going to look at
Bishop c4 whoops that's not right Bishop
c4 is our main loop and after the move
Bishop c4 we Castle okay and we leave it
up to white to decide what he's going to
do in this specific position the
grandmasters considered the move f2 f3
unnecessary and they don't like spending
the whole tempo for f3 they don't like
playing the move Queen d2 because of as
we've pointed out Knight g4 is a good
answer to Queen d2 most grandmasters
have played the move Bishop b3 so what's
the idea behind Bishop b3 the bishop is
a little bit of a it's it's not
protected out there it's a little bit of
a tactical target and so the bishop
simply steps back into safety now this
is again a major crossroads for black if
we play the move d7 d6 here we're right
back in a normal Sicilian dragon and all
of our beautiful subtle play to get the
accelerated dragon has been lost we gain
nothing through this move order by
playing d6 in this position so we have
to come up with a more insightful move
and that move surprisingly enough is the
move a 785 ok so what do you think the
purpose of the move a5 is
don't all guess at once precisely to
harass the bishop basically from blacks
perspective he would love to capture
this puck just that would just be
outstanding
we went upon our favorite living
condition but the problem with capturing
the pawn of course is is protected by
the knight it would cost as a knight and
that's not good
don't don't don't lose your pieces don't
let don't be like me don't lose your
pieces so with this move
a5 our intention is to play a for
harassing the bishop and if we could
force the bishop to capture the pawn on
a4 or the knight to capture the pawn on
a4 we want to follow up with Knight
takes e4 okay so after a5 White has a
problem what should white do what do you
think what's a good move for guessing
then push your pawn up to a for a very
very wise idea
push your pawn up to a4 okay so we we
have to go back for just a moment to
this position and you've heard me well
being a little bit critical about the
move d7 d6
because this transposes into what we
call the main line variation of the
Sicilian dragon well in a mainline
variation of the Sicilian dragon after
for example to move f3 Bishop d7 Queen
d2 we're about to get one of the wild
wild chess games going what white is
about to do is to castle with his King
to the Queen side we've already made a
commit
we made we castled a long time ago so we
set to white we telegraph to white this
is our address for our king okay
our opponent knows where our king is
already placed so he knows where to
focus now when white castles Queen side
it's one of those games one of those
sharp sharp positions where when we're
castles on opposite flanks it's our duty
to attack our opponent's king with a
flank attack and it's our opponents duty
to attack our king with a flank attack
now if I can include the move a five as
well as a four this is good for me the
black player because I've gotten white
to weaken his Kings position so the
inclusion of the move a five and a four
is actually quite well somewhat
favorable for black so although I do
like the move a four in this specific
position is actually kind of good for
black so another suggestion for white
what else could white do is he busted is
it hopeless
is it over yes in man what do you think
white you did yes but then if you play
the move Bishop c4 you kind of like
wasting some time you move your bishop
here once you drop back with the Bishop
twice and now you'll be moving the
bishop again third time however still
the suggestion of the ships e4 deserves
consideration for a very specific reason
now again you've heard me say keep this
tempo moving
serve don't just play d7 d6 but give
yourself the opportunity of playing d7
d5 in one go and this is an example of
the type of situation where that becomes
very useful for example after Bishop c4
you give me the option of capturing the
pawn on e4
so what's the idea behind that haven't
we mentioned a moment ago that if we
take this pawn on e4 just costs as a
night we blunder tonight ah not so fast
not so fast now thanks to the fact that
your Bishop on is on c4 and your night
is on e4 you give me the opportunity to
win my piece back with a move d7 d 5
okay I haven't necessarily won any
material but I'm very pleased that my
king is safe for the moment
my bishop is really good it's really
good on this diagonal and I'm either
going to take this bishop or I'm going
to take this knight now you can do
something about that you can move one
piece or the other you could for example
in this position take my knight and drop
back with your bishop but notice in the
resulting type of position what has
happened my bishop on g7 is on this nice
open diagonal my bishop has come to life
and I can snap off this pawn on b2 and
that would lead me black in a very good
position so we need to find another move
beside a4 as well as besides Bishop c4
what else could white play
f 3 very reasonable move f 2 F 3 okay so
now let me see if I've got this position
right so now after F 2 F 3 if I play the
move D 76 we're back into a dragon
position and I've committed my pawn to
a5 and well maybe that's not so good for
me
maybe that's actually good for you so
how about if I play the move d5 yeah
very good very good now things are
beginning to heat up and I'm about to
blow open the center of course if you
simply allow me to capture the pawn on
e4 I'll be very happy with the position
so with the move d7 d5 I'm taking a risk
your Bishop on b3 your knight on c3 your
pawn on e4 was like a warning sign
you're saying you can't play d5 I'll
capture that pawn on d5 and yet I played
it anyway
okay so this is I'm throwing down the
gauntlet this is a challenge how should
white capture the pawn on d5 what do you
guys think that's a good move for white
here
sorry Bishop takes d5 that's a good move
in fact there's three possibilities of
course there's Knight takes d5
there's Bishop takes d5 and this pawn
takes d5 so let's look at each one and
turn shall we okay so what would we do
if our opponent played Knight takes d5
well remember that we played the move
a5 with a specific idea right we wanted
to harass White's Bishop and that's
precisely what we're going to do we're
going to harass White's Bishop we're
going to go a five a four now don't fall
for this mistake if you're white don't
capture my knight on f6 Bishop takes f6
again and again I repeat myself very
often our bishop on this long diagonal
suddenly is creating some kind of very
nasty threats and I'm threatening to
capture this knight now if you try to
protect the knight on d4 with a move
Bishop here
can black win a piece can black win a
piece huh what do you think guys guys
and gals yes what would you do young man
from yes I can move my pawn from even to
e6 that is correct but after I move my
pawn D if I move my pawn to e6
immediately maybe my knight will get
captured so what I can do is I can trade
pieces first I can in this position I
can trade pieces Queen takes d4 and
notice that the Queens are opposing one
another or to put it more specifically
this bishop on d5 is pinned it can't
move because it's its Queen would be
left hanging so I could play the movie
se7en in X and I would win a piece yay
not only did I make it out of the
opening intact but I actually win
material so this would not be a good
line of play for for white you would
have to play Bishop c4 here I believe
okay
mainly okay so one of the first things
we should notice is that beside the fact
we're a pond down which makes us very
very upset
we've got to do something about that
right away is for the moment White's
king is still in the center we're very
pleased with ourselves just a second let
me give myself a pat on the back my king
is nice and safe this is a very good
thing it makes how our daddy's happy our
mommy's happy whenever we have a safe
King and it sets up the following we're
going to capture this knight on d5 which
once again opens up our bishop and we're
hoping we're hoping that our opponents
will fall for it and make a major
mistake and capture with the bishop
because this sets us right back up into
that situation we had a moment ago where
we could win a piece thanks to the pin
on the D file correct exactly so he
white would have to recapture with the
pawn
okay now what could we do if we're black
clearly our knight on c6 is under dire
threat we got to do something about that
geez and now Knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes doesn't give us
that desirable situation of a pin in our
favor do we have another move or do we
have other moves young man Knight e5 is
a most excellent move Knight e5 is a
most excellent move the pawn on d5 is
only defended by the bishop if we could
get the bishop to move away let's say to
retreat then we could win our pond
we are in a great shape right okay and
is there another move besides 95 on a
similar note we could also play Knight
to a5 the same idea right the knight is
better when it's centralized that's
correct however I always kind of think
of a chess game as like a market you go
to market and you're always bartering
with someone how much for the Apple how
much for the pepper how much for the
cherries and you're always weighing the
money you have in your pocket versus
what you can buy when you play the move
95 which is very good Knights need to be
centralized what the downside of putting
our knight on e5 it blocks the bishop so
even while we're patting ourselves on
our back because we understand that the
knight is better when it's centralized
we also have blocked our bishop
so we have to judge whether the knight
could be better on a5 or a fight so
let's bring up our audience and then the
variations we've been discussing so in
fact what I'd like to point out in this
specific position is Black has three
very good moves with his Knight what the
young man and I are discussing is that
in either the cases of Knight a5 or
Knight e5 he mentions that white could
play the move b3 which protects the
bishop and in cases of Knight takes the
pawn would recapture and guess what
white would be upon ahead ok now that's
not the end of the story in fact the
story could go on for a long long time
white is upon up a plows
Plus whites apana but if you notice that
the pawns are doubled that is to say
this pawn on c2 and this pawn on c4
occupy the same file and hence we use
the expression the pawns are double and
it's not going to be very easy for white
to defend this pawn in fact we can
imagine that when the bishop goes here
and the rook goes here and the Queen
goes here we could capture this pawn
right away so let's imagine that in this
position white plays the move Queen c7
attacking this policy for if I can take
this pawn on c4 and restore the material
balance and the pawn on d5 would also be
weak let's continue the line y could
defend the pawn with maybe Queen e2 or
either Queen d3 we have to choose one
let's choose d3 yes and let's imagine
that we play the move Bishop d7 now it
starts to dawn on us that well this move
rook c8 is coming with a big power but
we can go back could in this position
could black play a different move black
play it differently then Queen c7 I mean
tough huh what do you think Ben yeah I
know you're texting hit face burger yeah
that's uh that's very clever okay well
can I check my opponent because I all
always check it may be made right have
you ever heard that expression always
check it may be made so one of the first
moves
I would definitely investigate as check
and if checks aren't available the next
move I always investigate is a capture
can I capture something right and if
that's not available then I try to look
for a move but I always look at checks
first and then I always look for
captures so in this position this move
Queen c7 I would be very attracted to
but I'd also be very attracted to a
check isn't this disruptive to our
opponent after all it's not very
pleasant to suddenly be faced with a
check why could why - yes your men
Bishop back - D - fair enough
ok let's stop and think about this
position for a second now so far who's
been who's being who's done what to whom
I mean what I mean to say is hasn't
black kind of had an initiative he's the
one that's been pushing the action so to
speak his King is perfectly safe notice
how this Bishop once again is on this
beautiful diagonal and what with this
move Bishop d2 you're blocking the check
to your king and very nicely from whites
point of view you're attacking the Queen
well where can the Queen move now
where can one line see five fabulous
suddenly the position is clarifying
itself and we discover much to our
horror surprise that white is in serious
trouble we we use the expression in
chest deep do do you guys ever heard
what that name deep dude like really
really deep the Bishop attacks the
knight the Queen attacks the night once
this pawn on d5 fall a c4 falls part of
me this pawn on d5 is weak so Black has
already gotten an advantage in this
position now we're going to go back and
we're going to play oops
no we're going to play the other move
for a moment he takes d5 and I said
black had three good moves with his
knight I said 95 is an excellent move it
centralizes it our knight Knight a5 is
an excellent move it attacks the bishop
and we hope to win our pawn back on d5
and to keep our Bishop open our third
very good move which is very very common
in the accelerated dragon is the move
Knight d4 okay it's really your personal
choice or taste if you will as to which
move you prefer 95 95 94 at the point of
night before is very clear if we can win
our pawn back with the move Knight takes
d5 we're going to have an excellent
position simply excellent what could
white do what can white do young man
excellent move the knight back to e2 and
the reason you did that is because you
saw that your queen is now defending the
pawn on d5 that was very clever very
clever so now it's black to move and
before you all rush out and say I know I
know
think of how many good moves Black has
in this position I don't want to hear
one good move for black
I want to hear three Black has three
good moves in math okay so Julian I
think it was Bishop f5 which is a good
move right because with this Bishop
coming to f5 we want to play Knight
takes check to the King attack the rook
the knight would attack the bishop so
Bishop f5 is an excellent good move
Bishop takes V two wins our pawn back
that's also a good move and a4 a3 is
also remember that little pond that just
kind of like ran up the board and seemed
to do nothing
now our rook is getting active what a
dream what a dream come true it will be
to play a takes b2 will be only one
square away from Britain from promotion
and will be attacking that rook so we're
going to go back to this position and
where made us an interesting just
remarkable discovery that this solid
safe looking move f2 f3 allows us
tactical opportunities with the move d5
so it turns out
after the move f3 white ends up with
serious issues serious issue
you